♪♪
-Now, let's get to the news.
When asked by a reporter
over the weekend
if he had a message
for North Korean leader
Kim Jong-un,
President Biden said,
"Hello, period."
[ Laughter ]
Which sounds lame, but remember,
a hello followed by a period
is the scariest text
you can receive.
[ Laughter ]
In her new memoir, former Trump
advisor Kellyanne Conway writes
that her husband,
George Conway's, attacks
against the administration were,
"Sneaky, almost sinister,"
and it's honestly why she fell
in love with him all over again.
[ Laughter ]
Conway also writes that former
President Trump was,
"A feminist who repeatedly
supported and promoted her."
Said Trump, "Thanks, Maryanne."
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams
is reportedly thinking
about running for president
in 2024,
if President Biden
does not seek reelection.
Dude, have you seen what happens
to New York City mayors
who run for president?
It has about the same
success rate
as asking out the barista.
[ Laughter ]
During a parade over the weekend
in New York,
Rudy Giuliani called a heckler
a brainwashed ass[bleep]
who is probably as "demented
as President Biden."
Said an aide,
"That's a sky dancer."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Giuliani ] "Why are you
waving your arms around?"
[ Laughter ]
Former Vice President Mike Pence
said in a new interview,
that he's open to running
for president in 2024.
I mean, so many people at the
Capitol were telling him to.
"You better run, Mike Pence!
You better run!"
Krispy Kreme will give out
free doughnuts this week
to any high school
or college senior
that visits a store
wearing Class of 2022 apparel.
And Dunkin' said
they'd give a free doughnut
to anyone who comes in
wearing a shirt.
[ Laughter ]
Any shirt.
The luxury automaker
Mercedes-Benz
announced last week
that it has sold
the world's most expensive car
to a private owner
for $142 million.
Apparently, it cost that much
because the tank is full.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
a man in Wisconsin last week
celebrated his 50th anniversary
of eating a McDonald's Big Mac
almost daily
and has only missed eight days.
That's not bad.
Fifty years of Big Macs
and only eight heart attacks.
President Biden said
yesterday that
the U.S. economic recovery
is going to take some time.
Okay, "take some time" like
the Amazon option that
saves you a dollar,
or "take some time"
like "Avatar 2"?
If he were any more vague,
he'd be a Magic 8 ball.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said for
the third time yesterday
that the U.S.
would respond militarily
if China tries to invade Taiwan.
Well, at least he's capable
of taking a firm stand
on problems we don't have yet.
"Yeah, yeah, we'll fight China!
Student loans?
Uh, yeah, let me call
some people."
In her new memoir, ex-Trump
adviser Kellyanne Conway
acknowledges that former
President Trump
lost the 2020 election.
I know. I was surprised, too.
However, she does say he lost
to William Howard Taft.
She just can't -- can't help
but get one lie in there.
According to a new report,
ex-Trump attorney Michael Cohen
said in a recent deposition that
former President Trump was
afraid of getting pied in
the face by demonstrators.
I don't know. That feels
like some reverse psychology.
[ Imitating Donald Trump ]
"You know what?
You know what would
totally own me?
If someone threw an entire,
freshly baked pie
right in my face.
Even worse, if it had some
of that cinnamon crumble
stuff on top of it.
If they also hit me
with a side of whipped cream,
oh, I would be so delicious --
I mean, embarrassed."
[ Normal voice ] A guitar played
by the late Kurt Cobain
sold in an auction over the
weekend for nearly $5 million.
It's the perfect way to say,
"I don't get what he was
singing about."
[ Light laughter ]
That's working at home
with some stepdads right now.
That joke's landing with some
stepdads right now at home,
and I'm willing to suffer
through this moment
with you guys.
But I see you.
[ Whispering ] Stepdads.
Stepdads, I see you.
Sorry about everybody here.
They're doing their own thing.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] The fast food
chain Arby's announced yesterday
that it will add
a hamburger to its menu
for the first time
in its history,
but people don't go to Arby's
because they want a burger.
They go there because everything
else is closed.
[ Laughter ]
Bruce Springsteen
& The E Street Band announced
today that they'll go on
tour next year
after a six-year hiatus.
Though, just to be safe, they're
gonna put a sneeze guard
between Bruce and Stevie.
[ Light laughter ]
[Whispering ] Step-dads.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know why I tried to do
two for you in the same show.
[ Normal voice ] Firefighters in
New Jersey recently removed
a four-foot monitor lizard
from a tree
in a residential neighborhood.
Isn't that wild?
There's a tree in New Jersey.
[ Laughter ]
Don't shake your head, Wally.
Our cue card, New Jersey's Wally
over on cue cards is like,
"Ohh, trees."
[ Laughter ]
It's just very distracting
to read cue cards when you're
scoffing at the punchline.
-I have two trees in my yard.
-What did you say?
-I have two trees
in my own yard.
-Two trees? Well!
Ol' two-tree Wally.
[ Laughter ]
Are you gonna go to Wally's
two-tree summer party?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, New York City
yesterday removed its last
public payphone from service.
But don't worry,
anywhere else in New York
will still be a public restroom.
President Biden spoke from
the White House on Tuesday
and asked when the country
will be ready to
stand up to the gun lobby.
When we will?
That's like your landlord
saying,
"Ooh, you got to do
something about these mice."
[ Laughter ]
The White House announced --
has announced
that the K-Pop group BTS
will appear next week
with President Biden,
because the White House
is always looking for ways
to make Biden look even older.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at that.
That's like a Korean
remake of "Scooby Doo."
[ Laughter ]
"I would have gotten away with
it if it weren't for
these pesky kids
and their catchy hooks."
[ Laughter ]
Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker
said in a new interview that
he's never heard
former President Trump say
that the 2020 election
was stolen from him.
Even more troubling,
he also said,
"Who is this Herschel Walker
I keep hearing about?"
That's right,
Herschel Walker said that
he's never heard Trump say
that the 2020 election
was stolen,
which is kind of like saying
you've never heard
Flo talk about Progressive.
I've never heard her talk about
anything else!
Representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene
won this week's
Republican primary
in Georgia's
14th Congressional district.
But just for fun, she's going
to storm the Capitol anyway.
[ Laughter ]
It's a celebration storm!
MSNBC announced this week
that former White House
Press Secretary Jen Psaki
will host a new streaming show.
Well, let's hope
"White House to NBC"
goes better than
"NBC to the White House."
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
A romance novelist --
alright.
No one rememb--
I don't remember
what show that was.
It could've been on
any network.
[ Laughter ]
A romance novelist in Oregon
who wrote a book -- excuse me.
who wrote a blog post titled
"How to Murder Your Husband"
was convicted yesterday
of killing her husband.
[ Laughter ]
In case you're wondering how far
you have to go to get someone
to read a blog post.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
41% of Americans
said that their largest
single monthly expense
is rent or mortgage,
and one said dinosaur skulls.
[ Laughter ]
Amtrak this week released
pictures of its new
Acela trains, which will feature
contactless restrooms.
Well, contactless
depending on your balance.
[ Laughter ]
Walking down one of those
is like
walking down an old rope bridge.
And finally, a plaster cast
of the late singer
Jimi Hendrix's penis
is set to be unveiled next month
at the Phallological Museum
in Iceland,
which houses the world's largest
display of penises.
It costs adults
10 bucks to enter,
while members get in free.
[ Laughter ]
He wrote --
he writes in my voice.
That's what I like about him.
You guys,
that was the monologue.
♪♪